[Music]
we have new information on the missing
22 year old woman we've been talking
about this week gabby petito was last
seen in wyoming about three weeks ago
her family in long island new york wants
answers from her fiance the two had been
documenting their travels across the
country police call him a person of
interest but he has not been charged or
questioned in the case we're now
learning about an incident between the
couple our national correspondent jarika
duncan has been following this story
tarika good morning good morning to you
family is still holding on to hope a
police report from mohab utah shows
gabby petito and her fiance brian
laundry got into a physical altercation
on august 12th more than a week before
her last facetime with her mother police
say the couple agreed the incident was
more of a mental or emotional health
break than a domestic assault laundry
told police that traveling for the last
four or five months had created an
emotional strain between them and that
they both struggled with some mental
health issues although exactly what
those issues are is redacted in that
police report no charges were filed and
no one wished for charges to be filed
yesterday afternoon petito's parents
released a new statement that read in
part brian left gabby in the wilderness
with grizzly bears and wolves while he
sits in the comfort of his home brian
your silence is reprehensible petito's
stepfather has now traveled to wyoming
to search for her laundry has been in
florida since september first according
to police he and his parents have
retained an attorney who issued a
statement that laundry on the advice of
counsel is not speaking on the matter
yeah what more do we know about this
incident that happened after after
august 12th anything we we know that um
according to the police report
gabby was crying um
they did not believe that laundry was in
any harm they didn't believe that she
was any immediate harm they offered them
to stay in hotel rooms to sort of keep
them apart knowing that they had been on
this trip and maybe when cooler heads
prevail things would be better
they agreed to that the police officers
through a safe haven program gave brian
a hotel
and gabby chose to stay in the van
so
as for what happened even after that
august 12 incident
we just don't know and i think that at
the core is why the parents are so
frustrated because
you're with my daughter all this time
according to them and you're not
speaking to authorities to give us a
sense of what happened where could she
be tell us talk to us and what is he
thinking that he could come home without
her with the van and not answer any
questions and think that that's going to
be okay it's so upsetting and disturbing
i really like that family thank you very
much tarika